you mentioned aerospike engines
I think the internet uh informed me of
your love affair with their Spike edges
find somebody that looks at you the way
Tim not looks at Aerospace
uh what these are how do they work
um what's beautiful to them what how
practical are they why don't we use them
oh my God uh does it just boil down to
the design of the nozzle uh so maybe can
you explain how is it possible to
achieve this thing for an engine to be
as efficient at uh in a vacuum on sea
level and in all different conditions
you know what I love about this is that
every question you've asked me is like a
one hour video
now boil it down to 45 seconds
so the aerospike engine basically is an
inside out engine more or less so with a
traditional engine you know we've talked
about the combustion chamber and the
throat and then it expands out into the
nozzle those walls are containing the
pressure right
airspike is the opposite it's basically
the pressure of the engine is on the
outside of it and it's pushing inward
against a spike
so it's it's almost like it's like like
the difference of if you were let me
think about this if you were standing in
like a a tent or a TP right and you put
your arms at the top and you pushed your
arms out like into an iron cross or
something you know you could physically
lift the tent just by pushing outwards
on the tent walls right well that would
be like a traditional nozzle now
aerospice would be almost like squeezing
an ice cube you know if you squeeze an
ice cube you can push in on it and kind
of that wedge force will shoot that ice
cube so that's kind of what is happening
we have the high pressure gases on the
outside of the spike squeezing in on
that Spike and that's and then it's
pushing up against the you know because
it's equal on both sides against like
kind of the ramp is pushing up against
the rocket so that's where that Force
comes in it's against the nozzle against
the chambers the hard part with an
aerospike so the cool okay I guess the
cool thing about an aerospike is
that it can operate
um in space you can have what's known as
a really big expansion ratio so that's
your ratio between the throat the area
of the throat versus the area of the
nozzle exit and remember how the bigger
the nozzle is the it's con continually
just converting more and more is
converting that high energy hot high
pressure gas into a cooler
and cooler lower pressure and faster gas
so each little millimeter along that
nozzle is just getting it lower pressure
and cooler but faster
now if you take a big nozzle on Earth
and you at sea level and you fire it you
can actually get even though we're going
from say 300 bar the Raptor engine
um you know our atmosphere at sea level
is about one bar is pretty much exactly
one bar
um depending on conditions but you can
actually get a nozzle to get way below
one bar of pressure so every little you
know you can go from 300 bar in just two
meters down to one bar or below one bar
there's actually a limit you can
actually only expand it below you know
we'll say something like 70 percent so
you can get down to like point seven bar
at nozzle exit before the pressure of
the atmosphere is actually squeezing in
on that exhaust and tearing it away from
the walls of the engine the walls of the
nozzle exit and what happens is it's
it's kind of unpredictable you get these
Pockets these oscillations and they'll
be so extreme that they'll end up just
destroying the nozzle so you can't lower
you can't have a bigger expansion ratio
then again relatively speaking some
something like 0.7 like you can't go
below you can't get that pressure exit
too much below ambient air pressure
before flow separation can destroy the
engine so how come this engine can do so
well in in different pressure conditions
so because it's inside out the ambient
pressure is pushing the exhaust gas into
the wall as opposed to a conventional
engine that exhaust get or the ambient
air is actually squeezing the exhaust
gas away from the walls of the engine
and that squeezing away from is what can
be destructive so that since the
instance is kind of inside out the
ambient air is pushing the exhaust gas
into the engine walls so you can't have
flow separation you won't have flow
separation now what happens is so you
can have this huge amazingly like
efficient vacuum engine that's that's
has a we'll say a 200 to 1 expansion
ratio which is really big like a lot of
sea level engines are like 35 40 50 to 1
expansion ratios and then in space you
know it's common to use like 150 180 200
to one expansion ratios so an aerospike
can have something like 200 to one it's
just at the at sea level it's kind of
just getting pushed and it's kind of
getting cut off early almost but it
doesn't matter it's not like destructive
it's just not running at its maximum
efficiency as it climbs in altitude as
the ambient air gets thinner and thinner
and thinner it just inherently is
pushing less and less and less against
the walls of that aerospike engine so it
actually continually gets more efficient
at you know as it climbs in altitude as
as does the normal engine but the
difference is that you can use that huge
expansion ratio at sea level and you
can't use a huge expansion ratio at sea
level with reproduction traditional
nozzle has anyone actually flown on a
spike engine no aerospike engine to date
has ever been flown on an orbital rocket
why not and would you like to see a
future where they're used
purely purely because I think they're
cool yeah you know in the same way
that's at the core of your love affair
with air Spike engines it's just and I
said this in my video actually they're
outside before I came in here I saw an
RX7 on in the streets that I just love
and that uses a rotary engine on paper
the rotary engine is like more efficient
does you know smaller more efficient all
these things but in practice it's like
the thing is actually just like
unreliable hot and it you know it it
blah blah blah blah Burns oil it's kind
of the same thing with the aerospike
engine like yes on paper it's more
efficient but now you have a lot more
surface area of your your your your
throat area no matter what is going to
have uh the the throat of the rocket
engine is always where it's the hottest
you know it's the hardest thing to cool
and with a narrow Spike if you know if
it's inside out now your throat is no
matter what like way bigger you know
it's almost like the size of the nozzle
exit normally but now it's your hardest
thing to cool and you have a ton of it
and you also have two edges of it no
matter what so even if you have like a
you know a circle inside a circle
you have like a just insane amount more
surface area to cool with a limited
amount of fuel don't forget you're using
your fuel as your as your coolant so if
you also now take your throw area and
you have
um
x amount of space that you need to cool
you only have you have a limited Supply
it's like oh it's sorry this is the
stuff that just are there ideas of for
cooling
um or for cooling out Spike engines it's
the same physics apply for aerospike as
they would so you just run into you just
run into a limitation like at some point
I'm not flowing enough propellant my it
scales it scares scales kind of poorly
you know what I mean like you can
increase the thrust of an aerospice by
making it bigger and increase the mass
flow and the fuel going through the
throats or the throat but at the same
time like it just it's at the end of the
day
it's physically possible it's a lot more
complex you have a lot of issues with
Cooling and it's just you end up kind of
right back where you started so it's
like is it worth it to just keep going
down this Rabbit Hole you're trying to
engineer this thing to work when like
you could have probably spent a tenth of
the amount of time just slightly
increasing the performance of your
normal engine in the first place you
know
again I'm going to anthropomorphize uh
that lesson and apply it to my dating
life and once again